i got nervous to get it looked at
because i knew how much pain i was in
like i couldn't
really push my wrist back i couldn't
like at home i couldn't hold a plate or
a cup
um so after each game i was wearing like
a brace
to keep it you know stabilized to sleep
in it
but i was i was nervous to go get it
checked out
because i never want somebody to tell me
i can't play
[Music]
the man himself
jason tayden what's up what's up i mean
i would say like it's good to see you
but i just watched you play
in jamal crawford's program you want to
bring this to you oh yeah
i will say i need you to set the scene
for everybody that wasn't there
about how good the energy was in there
but also how hot it was
yeah uh
the atmosphere was was crazy my first
time in seattle
even pulling up to the gym all the fans
waiting outside it was everything that
you could expect it to be um
so you know you walk in we walk into
practice gym and you know you see
everybody and
getting dressed and getting ready for
the game
you know i'm doing my warm-up stuff like
i would before a real game um
but when we walked up the steps
and they opened the doors
it was uh
it was incredible yeah walking up to the
court
hearing them say our name and the kid's
going crazy i think that's really what
you're doing for the excitement on kids
faces
um is nothing better than that yeah it
really was that's what stick out or
stuck out to me too was like whenever
you would be near a kid or lebron would
be near a kid or not he's near a kid
they almost can't believe it like their
faces just light up and i think that
obviously because we work in this
industry we're in sports we're so used
to seeing all the stars but to so many
of them
that's the only time they'll probably
ever see you all that close for sure and
it's just like really special no it was
it was a it was incredible and
you know i think i'm a big deal but when
lebron walked out there
and it's like i know brian and like we
see him all the time but you know these
people would see him on tv you know they
haven't seen him playing years
so the kids lost their mind when he
walked on the court and that was just
like that was a cool moment to see to be
there and see that yeah and it's like he
walks in and he's like hyping up the
crowd it was like he was parting the red
sea like everyone walked out and
everyone separated it was really really
cool okay so were people looking in
they're just on twitter and they see
okay lebron's going to play in a pro-am
then dejontias and paulo and chet than
you how does this happen how does
everyone come together uh
for me it was super last minute um
i have been talking to jamal throughout
the summer
and i told him i would be out in la and
once i start back working out you know i
would love to come up for a weekend and
uh
you know because obviously i took some
time off after the finals and it got
down to the last two weekends and
thanks to you i couldn't go today
because we had this
and uh i had
prior arrangements next weekend yeah um
so yesterday was only real day and you
had you played a part in
in me going um with you and jamal
convincing me um
but you know i just i called brian at
eight o'clock on friday night and he was
like yo come up like we'd be on the same
team
and uh i was like all right yeah i've
never been to seattle so i got on the
plane saturday morning uh
and it happened yeah it was such a
moment i mean okay you made what five
threes six threes just in the first half
first quarter yeah for my bad first
quarter
you were really feeling it what do you
attribute like that to so early uh the
crowd yeah the atmosphere playing an
environment that you've never played in
before
and just you know even though it's a
game for fun
i'm such a competitor that like
you know i wasn't just going up there to
get some shots up like i know it's not
the the playoffs but i wanted to put on
a show you know i wanted
somebody to leave that gym and be like
man i remember that day you know jason
tatum came to seattle and lit it up um
so the atmosphere you know it's nba guys
on the court
you know how hot it was um
you know us
i feel like that's when i'm in my
element and you know i get between those
lines you know i just you know get in my
zone
has a summer after going to the finals
fell different than your other summers
a thousand percent yeah
so many different dynamics right you
know we played two and a half months
longer than everybody else
i uh
and i don't have [ __ ] to celebrate yeah
right so it's like you get all the way
to the finals
you play longer than everybody else and
then you know you have nothing to
celebrate
um you have such a shorter off season um
you know
and
every i
i realize playing in the finals
everybody watches the finals
so if i was recognizable before the
season
it has been magnified times a thousand
um
ever since you know the season's been
over has been over with but i would
think and correct me if i'm wrong
you're probably treated differently
amongst the peers like making it to the
finals is a stamp of something on you do
you feel that for sure uh
you know
we
we all respect each other and we know
how hard it is to accomplish first team
all nba or going to the finals whatever
it may be so
uh
i guess i you know you do get a little
more respect or um
you know from other guys because you
know being this is my fifth year um you
know you know how hard it is to do that
and you know even getting to that point
you know so guys you know tip the head
or whatever and you know when i see him
yeah because obviously you're already
jason tatum but like once you go to the
finals
you're jason tatum you know like what
does that mean it means that you
accomplished the thing that people
expected of you obviously you fell short
but you made it to that point and it
felt like that was such a monkey
on your back too yeah uh but like when
you say you're jason tatum like me and
my mom joke about joke about it all the
time it's hard for me to view myself how
other people view me yeah like i i feel
like i'm that same kid that lived with
my mom and back in st louis and like
you know to her i'm her baby it's a
deuce i'm just daddy yeah but
you know
people like when you reference it like
that it's still like i'm not used to
that if that makes sense but i mean to
that kid at the pro-am when you're in
front of him
he's like no no this is
jason tatum and i do think you probably
are at a point in your life where you're
wondering okay i know like who i am at
my core but i also know that there's all
these other people around that think i'm
something else and do you ever think to
yourself what is that identity or do you
feel strong in what that identity is
uh that is a great question
and it's something that you just have to
adjust to
um it's not normal
it isn't to
go in public places and
people who lose their mind or you walk
into a restaurant or the gas station
and people just immediately pull their
phone out and record you
and you know
people say like well you asked for that
you know being in your position
um which i guess is true but it's still
you know i'm still like a human being
and
and there's a balance right you know
going into the gym and seeing kids lose
their mind is is one thing but you know
walking into a restaurant and
people
trying to grow people people older than
me
that's that's the first to get the thing
that gives me is like kids i understand
i could
have a
sandwich in my mouth and the kid would
tap me on my hand like can i get a
picture i understand but it's like when
it's adults
and they like trying to sneak a picture
in the restaurant it's like
you know
how would you feel somebody did that to
you it's just not it's not normal yeah
so what do you feel like you have given
up to be who you are
who
any sense of normalcy
privacy um
he and every yeah it's just like
everybody
exaggerates anything you do anything you
say anywhere you are
um good bad or indifferent
um
and just being able to do things
without any interruption i guess yeah
okay so i'm gonna try and make this
question make sense
but is being like jason tatum the
basketball player in like direct
conflict with what your personality is
um
no because i think i play basketball the
same way that i act
okay but i mean like would you say
you're an introverted person would you
say that you're a shy person you say
you're outgoing like it's having to be
what everyone wants you to be
opposite of like what you would be if
you were just at home
uh
i'm not shy i'm not the most outgoing
person
[Music]
i don't know like if i don't know you
i like yeah because like i don't think
you're shy but i would get why someone
would think like if you don't know me
people tell me all the time like you
know before
i met you i thought you were this way or
i assume these things about you you know
you never really speak during the game
i've had teammates
like i remember josh richardson came to
the team this year and he was like
he was like yo
you actually really cool
i'm like damn thanks he was like bro
like every time we played against each
other you just never said anything
i said well j rich i didn't know you
you're like yeah
it's as simple as that yeah
but you know around my friends and
family you know i
joke all the time and play and laugh
but i guess i've just always been
a more laid-back person and i guess
that's what um
most people see um
you know most people don't know the real
me yeah no i feel that you know i always
think about when i interviewed kemba
walker for my gq piece
and one thing he talks about is like you
know when i met jason i just thought he
was just this little light-skinned kid
from duke so what role do you think like
playing at duke
plays and the perception that people
have of you
yeah the the narrative around
kids that go to duke especially like
before my time and like when i got there
and even when i was growing up it was
like
you know
guys like grant hill go to duke which is
i love grant but like he's good you know
privileged two-parent households are
like
you know they take the
the good kids like you know they don't
take the kids from around the block or
you know from the inner city um
and not that i didn't like duke growing
up i just never thought that like coach
k would want me to go there like he
would come to my house
so
yeah going to duke definitely plays a
part i'm light skinned
i got curly hair
all right i
dressed nice so you know there's
definitely a
perception that comes with that until
you you never really get to know me yeah
no absolutely and it's funny because i
remember when i was talking to kim about
it me and him were also just discussing
like how we know that is what people
think of you but it really is very
opposite of what you're actually like so
that's always interesting i want to get
into in a bit later how your personality
plays a role into how you lead and also
how you play basketball but of course i
want to talk about the finals
so when i say
2022 nba finals what image pops in your
head um
you know us walking off the court at
home
and seeing them celebrate on our floor
that is a
image
a memory of feeling that you know i'll
probably never ever forget
how often do you think about that image
every day
[Music]
and it doesn't help every time i see
somebody you know
man good job in the finals you'll be
back i was rooting for you i'm just
constantly reminded every day
um and that's the tough part about the
off-season after you lose it's just like
you
human nature would you know want you to
be like no i just can't wait to get back
there but it's like nope you gotta start
back over
you gotta take the proper steps you
gotta rest and recover
get ready for the training camp going to
training camp all preseason start the
regular scene like it's a process you
can't just like through it and be like
yeah we're going to get back there
because it's not promised yeah um and we
can we can't have that mindset that um
you know it's gonna be given to us
so what's that post-finals process for
you meaning like okay have you
re-watched that series
yeah uh it was tough yeah
and from the standpoint of like
regardless of what everybody was saying
about me and how i played um afterwards
you know i never really pay attention to
that good or bad you know i know what
i'm capable of and i know
i could have done more and that was the
toughest part of you know feeling like i
let
my team down at the biggest moment um
and that hurt me more than what anybody
else could have said or you know could
think about me
you know those
three four days afterward i was i was
miserable
i really really was and
it took some time to like you know kind
of get out of that funk um
and just kind of enjoy my life enjoy
being around my son and my family yeah
so when you say you're miserable what
does that mean how did that like
manifest in your day-to-day
um i i
it's just tough um you know because i
feel like sometimes i come off so laid
back that i don't know if people
understand how much
i invest into this game how much
i care how hard i work um because i'm
not like the loudest or you know may
show everything
um but it was just so tough because i
literally gave everything that i had
and you know
to feel like i ran out that i didn't
have anything left to give
and we were so close um
you know really you know i didn't have
appetite i didn't want to talk to
anybody i didn't want to go anywhere
you know i just was like in my house for
like three four days straight you know
didn't want to do anything
um
because i just know how hard it is
to get to that point and thinking about
everything that you know i and my team
went through
to get there um
and not getting over getting over that
hump
was the worst is the worst feeling
so when you're watching it and you're
feeling these feelings
do you say to yourself
i'm a better player than what i showed
in these finals
oh for sure and you know
everybody knows that and
you know that's why i don't take offense
to you know what everybody was saying
because if
i wasn't that good you know they
wouldn't have talked about me all right
so
you know some people would kill to be in
that position for everybody to be
talking about them good or bad
um
so i mean
as it's all of what what should i have
done differently you know should i have
taken a few more games off during the
regular season
to prepare for that
i wish we would have closed out this
series and six instead of seven and that
extra travel day there and back you know
could have saved our legs it's just
things like that that i've thought about
you know day in and day out yeah and i
mean i'm sure there's 80 million
different scenarios that you could run
in your head to say maybe if this
happened this wouldn't have happened we
would have won whatever the case may be
but i think there is a lot of power that
comes in like being at peace with
knowing you did what you could and
knowing that you're gonna have another
season to hopefully prove that again too
how do you make like how do you find
that positive out of it
oh it's tough yeah um
but you know my my coaches and my
teammates know that
uh
you know i i gave them all um
and i just i honestly i ran out and it's
not an excuse right uh
what does that mean you've said that you
said like i feel like i ran out what do
you mean by that i was exhausted um
i was literally exhausted i
i don't know if it was
i think it was you know we started off
we at one point was like 25 and 28.
so
go from the 11th c to the second seed
and essentially we are playing
you know 40 games 35 games
you know the last you know half of the
season as if like we have to win every
game
um so kind of being in like
not panic mode but like you know that
extreme sense of urgency yeah for 40
straight games and then going to the
playoffs and
the road we took was the toughest road
that anybody would have had to take to
the finals um
and i think just you know all things
considered
it's a lot of things i've thought about
you know changing my diet or you know
maybe i could have taken some more games
off
just prepare a little bit differently
maybe in january
for june and not wait till i get to june
um to try to figure some things out yeah
now i know every single person in this
room has heard people say
it's so hard to get to the finals like
it's hard to make it there you gotta get
over the hump you gotta get there and um
until this one
we were all the same in terms of what we
thought about the road to the finals
what did you think like how hard did you
think it was before you got there
and then what did you really realize
about how hard it is once you got there
because i feel like it cannot be
overstated how difficult that path is
i mean you got
first second and third round best of
seven we played kd and kyrie
in the first round and we swept them but
if you go back
buzzer beater layup
second game we won by
seven third game win by nine
fourth game we won by like five so we
had we swept them but each game was
extremely extremely tough um
and then we go play the defending champs
and you know that wasn't
a team that was just as big as we were
and you know they were missing chris um
but
they were extremely physical great
defensive team obviously they got
giannis so
we beating each other up for seven games
we get out of that we gotta leave the
next day to go to miami and
if we were the best defensive team they
were the second best defensive team in
the playoffs yeah and yeah we went to
the finals
but game seven that shot that jimmy took
that three to
that could have sent us home yeah
like
my stomach
dropped yes
like i remember him coming down the
court he pulled up for three i didn't
even look at the basket i looked in the
crowd
because i was like i can't i can't look
at that yeah
oh my gosh can you imagine so just like
little like
one little change and we wouldn't have
been there yeah
so
knowing that right knowing all of the
things that have to go your way to make
it to the finals
knowing everything the team has to do
knowing you went last year and you fell
short
is there like a scared voice in the back
of your head that says
what if i don't make it back
no i never i never
think of like
the worst case or like
i'm never nervous or
doubtful you either succeed or you fail
right in my mind it's black and white
you either
i'm like they're gonna make this last
second shot or i'm gonna miss it
and i know it's
a lot of people in the league that would
be scared to take that shot
because they're afraid of
what could you know happen um and i
believe i you know
i'm gonna make it back to the final i
believe i'm gonna win one i believe i'm
gonna make that shot
um and if it doesn't happen you learn
from it yeah so it's never like
you know listen to this voice like you
know what if what if and if you like if
you focus on that it's
you're like holding yourself back
because you gotta realize people are
gonna
say whatever people are gonna talk talk
and my mom always told me
i mean
at least they talking about you yeah so
you know i never really
lose much sleep about this things like
that and i think something else you have
on your side too is like
you know who you are like you're a
person that has a very solid like belief
in who you are and what you can do and i
think that when you step into a role
like this and you are star in this
league
and you're wavering on who you are it
can be difficult but because you have
that solid foundation you're always
going to be able to like bounce back to
the next thing and look forward to the
next thing which is really important
i remember and i think i wrote it down
but the day before the finals you were
in a press conference
and you said let me see
i haven't
you said there have been times where i
questioned am i the right kind of person
to kind of lead a group like this
give me an example of a time you
questioned yourself or what you meant by
that the lowest point i say this all the
time the lowest point of the season was
um
we were up 25 in new york
and rj barry hit a three over me to win
the game
the night before
we lost to san antonio on the back to
back at home
uh i think jb missed the layup to win
the game
and uh
before that i was out for like six days
i had covet
so
we were already like
towing the line of 500
i get covered i come back
we lose to san antonio we up 25 in new
york and we lose
and i remember on the bus to the uh
airport i would just sit there like
this [ __ ] is hard
it is it is
it is hard
being you know the guy on a team
where you're supposed to you know
lead them in the right direction night
in and night out
um
is is hard and
moments like that
um
make you appreciate winning
and um
like i tell people all the time my first
and third year
i was extremely you know fortunate but i
was on a really really good team and i
say that as to say every night that we
played i expected us to win
my fourth year
and the like the first like that stretch
of the beginning of this season
that same level of like i didn't know
like
i knew we were good i knew we were
talented but we had we didn't put it put
it together so
like going into an arena in a game of
like
[ __ ] i don't know what's going to happen
like it could go either way yeah
and i remember us getting back to that
you know we won nine straight before the
um
all-star break and then coming after
all-star break
every game we played after that
i expected us to win like i went into
this like we're gonna win tonight and i
was like i haven't felt that feeling
since my third year and my first year
so you know
having those tough moments really made
me appreciate
you know when it's going good because
it's it's not always peaches and cream
you know
yeah there's the
flow but you really you felt that shift
yes yeah
okay i feel like everyone kind of felt
that shift so it's just interesting to
hear you say that because it was like
very clear when it said okay they're
getting this together they're figuring
this out so when you talk about like
questioning yourself and then growing
out of that do you now fully and
wholeheartedly know that you can lead
that team for sure it's like
i was already extremely confident
and that's like oh [ __ ] y'all let me get
to the finals
it's like
all right
i know how to get there and i just gotta
i'm trying to do a little bit more yeah
but it's like like you said like i'm
extremely comfortable with who i am and
i've always been extremely confident
um
and that just continues to build and
build year in the year out
so we talk about this long season and
because seasons are long a lot of wear
and tear happens during the season did
you have to deal with any injuries
throughout this season
uh
actually i did um
there was a
we played the hawks on a sunday
or monday whenever the super bowl was we
played the hawks at home
and uh
i remember driving
back
to the house and i had my watch on and
in the car
i keep looking at my wrist because it's
like something is weighing on it
so
you know long story short
my wrist was really really bothering me
and uh
you know i started taping my wrists i
had a pad on it and i started taping my
wrists
in game yeah
in the game uh
and my trainer nick who is becoming
famous by the day
we had talked about getting it looked at
before all-star break
and i was like fine that's cool
but as all-star break approached
i got nervous to get it looked at
because i knew how much pain i was in
like i couldn't
really
push my wrist back i couldn't like at
home i couldn't hold a plate or a cup
so after each game i was wearing like a
brace
to keep it you know stable i had to
sleep in it
but i was i was nervous to go get it
checked out
because i never want somebody to tell me
i can't play
you know if anybody knows me my
teammates like i never want to miss a
game
i've tried to play every game of every
season that i can um i hate coming out
you know he getting subbed out i hate
missing so
i i like pushed it to the side i didn't
go get it checked out um
before all-star break
fast forward
to right before the playoffs during the
play-in game we had six or seven days
off and nick was like yo we got to get
it looked at i'm like all right that's
cool but like it's the playoffs i don't
care what they say like i'm playing yeah
come to find out this was eight weeks
later that
they it showed that i had uh
had a non-displaced
fracture
in my wrist and it was like it was small
but it was still still yeah like a
non-displaced chip so like i chipped the
bone but it didn't like
leave the surface right um but it has
shown that the bone that grew over it so
it healed but it was still pain i was
still in pain because i kept getting it
hit or falling on it
uh
so like i guess i played with like
somewhat of a fracture for like two
months um wow
and then in the playoffs there was a
play against against milwaukee in game
three
um i dunked it giannis chased me down
and he fouled me and i fell into
the um to like the crowd and that was
the most painful it's been since
that day um that i heard it and i ended
up getting a cortisone shot in my wrists
um
that night and you could see it uh
yeah it's like much lighter i've lost
like color in my hand because it kills
the fat cells and there's not a lot of
fat in my hand so like i've lost color
right there
but you know after each game i would
have to like wear a brace
you know to shoot around and i would
take it off before the camera saw me and
then
you know pre-game taking my nap but i
have to put it back on you know just to
make sure it was stable so no one knew
you were dealing with this injury
besides like internally yeah it saw the
team yeah but it's like in my mind if i
if i'm going out there to play it's like
nothing matters like right if you
everybody's banged up a little hurt
you know if you're injured then you
can't play but that was my whole reason
of
i was scared to get an mri because i was
like something is wrong but like i don't
want anybody to tell me i can't play
yeah so but
in what ways if any did that injury
actually affect how you played
it was just tough you know this is not
my dominant hand but you know
it wasn't as stable and any time
driving to the lane falling somebody
smacking it it was just like this
extreme like excruciating pain right
here and you know oftentimes if you pay
attention closely i'm like shaking my
hand or i'm like at the free throw line
like trying to like calm it down
um
you know that would be every game
really
oh my goodness and now how does it feel
uh it's all good you know taking time
off to let it heal properly and you know
not get re-aggravated
um and things like that yes definitely
knock on wood and also shout out to nick
making sure you and again
girl nick i hope you're out there
watching um but no i mean i'm glad it
doesn't bother you anymore and obviously
i wish you an injury-free uh rest of
your career um
obviously there has been a lot of talk
and focus on this turnaround that the
team had how did it happen all these
things i don't necessarily want to know
how the turnaround happened i want to
know what conversation
made the turnaround happen
because i hear there was a
players only meeting involved around
this time um
i wouldn't say it wasn't like a one sit
down meeting
we had a good group and obviously we
made trades you know midway through the
season
but we didn't like we always had a good
group and we always had guys that
were willing and wanted to buy in and
wanted to figure it out
and i just tell people all the time like
i just didn't know what it was but we
were like one click away
and once like i
once i've realized that you know once we
figure it out that we're going to take
off and
um i give all the credit to you know the
guys on the team coaching staff
excuse me emay um
you know everybody nobody's
you know demeanor or feelings wavered we
know yeah we came back from a west coast
trip we was one in four
and it was just like it wasn't like
you know we might not figure it out i
was just like once we do
we just gotta do it and uh you know
that's when i i always had faith because
you know everybody
was always in good spirits um
and you know and once we did
i don't know what it would change but
you know we never looked back but is
there a conversation that sticks out
from that time
i mean people always talk about some
conversation me and jb had
but i mean it wasn't like we never
talked to each other and one day we
talked like we always
had conversations um
i mean maybe some days like yo we like
maybe need to do more or
we need to like watch film together a
little bit more or whatever it is but
there wasn't like uh
you know this formula i sit down yeah
i mean i think it's clear to everyone
that like for whatever reason there's
always like a jalen brown jason tatum
conversation in the media everyone's
talking about
do you guys get along are you friends
can you co-exist all these things
and i'm sure for some of you you believe
a lot of that is a media thing
but one thing i i really think about
when i think about youtube is when i had
bradley on the show we were talking
about him and john wall and he was like
you know john and i didn't really have
an issue with each other but the media
talked about it so much that we had to
have a conversation about the media and
about one another did you and jaylen
also have to have like a similar
this is what's going on let's clear the
air and figure out why this is happening
uh
not clear to air but more just like
you know let's block out all the noise
regardless of what they say we believe
that we can coexist that we can
be the leaders on this team and you know
get all the way
um because you know i believe in how
hard you work and how much you care and
you believe in how much i how much i
care how hard i work
um and it's going to be that much better
when we do figure it out
um but you know the media does have like
an obsession with like
the jays right i guess you know we both
kind of got a similar first name
a year apart but it's like we're two
totally different players
um but everybody just likes to group us
in together and this
i don't know where it came from
but you know it makes for a better story
i guess
well i mean we everyone knows
definitively now like you all work we've
seen it you all made it to the finals
together but was there a moment where
you were like okay
can we work will we be able to make this
work
i know i always knew we could yeah um
you know everybody talking about
you know they actually got to trade one
or the other they got a pick and it's
like wait it's two guys that's under
26
you know
at you know one of the best players in
their respective position um you know
two-way players
like why would you ever want to split
that up and it's like nobody can win a
championship together until they do it
yeah so i was like yeah we haven't won
one so yeah you could say we can't do it
but you know it's not like
we don't have any time left yeah both
still young yeah i always wonder this
too and again i think about what bradley
was talking about
he said that so much of it too was like
two people that both wanted to be the
guy for them and i wonder sometimes
the role that plays with like
both of you know you're good both of you
know your stars and you're figuring out
how to both be stars on one team does
that make sense
but do you feel like that played a role
at all
i don't think so no um i've got a great
deal of respect for him and and likewise
and
there's no
like competition like i when he made his
first all-star team i was extremely
happy for him because i know how much
that meant him how much how hard he
worked for that and that he deserved it
um
and you know it's enough
money and attention and shots or
whatever to go around
we we on the same team and we're trying
to accomplish something together no
matter how many points
either of us score
when we wasn't winning that [ __ ] did not
matter but when we started winning and
we both was playing well
you know then you know winning cares
everything when you're not winning then
they could pin nitpick at any little
thing but when you win
you know everybody's happy
also before we move on from jalen i want
to give you a chance to like clear the
air on something um you know when you
and katie were working out everybody
made a very big deal about the photo and
i don't really think people understand
what the off-season in l.a is like
everyone is working out together um so
just talk about that photo that moment
and that it was what it actually was for
you it goes back to your earlier
question like what did you give up being
jason tatum it's like they exaggerate
everything i do right i've known katie
since i was in high school
we were on the usa team together we
spent
five weeks together last year from vegas
to tokyo we won a gold medal like you
know we have a a bond like that's my
brother
um and it's like
i'm not too proud to say katie's one of
the best players ever so if like
one of the best players wants to work
out with you and i could learn some
things for him like why would i say no
and it's just
if you worry about if you worry too much
about what other people think are going
to say you're driving yourself crazy
yeah
and it's crazy that
i can't work out with somebody
no yeah
yeah um you know trying to get better
yeah
you know the other thing i never
understand too about social media and
how these things get started i'm like
why are y'all acting like we were doing
this in secret like we posted the photo
so we clearly don't think there was like
something going on we were just working
out but everybody spins it and makes it
their own thing and it's like if this
would have if trade rumors would have
never came out nobody would ever said
anything right i've been cool with kd
before whatever
people said or didn't say on the
internet about a trade or anything like
that yeah no it's the internet is i
always say people when i just had mark
cuban on the show we're like the
internet's not a real place like i went
to draymond's wedding like they just
beat us in the finals and
you know it was kind of tough seeing all
the team there but like
you know draymond is a great friend of
mine and you know i felt honored that he
wanted me to be at that special day yeah
it was like you know we've
had a relationship before we played in
the finals and everybody just thinks
like basketball is
is is your life and you shouldn't have a
life outside of that yeah okay but also
the photo y'all all took so good
in the booth oh it's so good that was it
so how did that also shout out to ray bb
by the way all her photos were fire um
but in that photo obviously you're out
the wedding but like what happens
they're taking the photos and then are
they just like
jason
yeah uh
so i've seen the photo booth and it was
a long line and
braun and uh steph and draymond they
took a picture with they all got four
rings
and uh i was
walking
past
and rich rich poe was right there and he
grabbed me he like yo come on take this
picture with us i wasn't gonna say no
i was like all right we got in the
picture we took like a normal one
and then draymond was like man it's my
wedding we got turned up so we just
started dancing yeah no the the photos
are so good that's when like you have to
get framed oh for sure yeah that's gotta
like go in the house ryan it's it's so
nice um okay i want to go back to
something we were talking about a bit
earlier which is about you being vocal i
think that when you first entered the
league there was a lot of people that
had this idea that like you weren't
vocal there was criticisms about you
being vocal and your leadership have you
seen yourself become more vocal as the
years
like went by
yeah in my own way yeah you know because
you have to be who you are in that for
sure yeah
you know everybody tries to
put what they want
on you like what they think you should
be doing you know they put that on you
and
you know if you're going to be a celtic
grade and you have to act like kg it's
like i'm not kevin garnett like i don't
come off like that um or you have to
act this way
uh
and you just like you got to be
comfortable with being yourself you got
to do what works for you you know i'm
not
the the loudest guy that's going to do
all the antics to show
the crowd or show that
the people on tv that you know i care
you know i talk in the huddle i talk in
the locker room you know when it's
needed um and my teammates know that um
you know i'm the first one in the gym
i'm always the last one to leave
um
and that's something that they don't you
know that the world doesn't see
and it's like
the more they try to push something on
you
the more i'm gonna be like you know what
i'm actually gonna continue to do it the
way i want to do it yeah um
because that's who i am yeah
i mean would you think like say i had a
graph
would you being vocal correlate to your
performance as well like as you
continued to become more confident who
you were as a basketball player did you
be more confident in how you led does
that make sense
um
i think i'm
trying to get what you're saying like
you becoming more vocal what do you
attribute that to like as you continue
to do it more and more why
you just get more experience yeah um
i'm sure you're a better
interviewer now than you were five years
ago yeah and that just comes with
experience um
and that's all i really can attribute it
to um i was 19 when i first got here now
i'm 24 and
i'm just a different person and
i'll have more experience in four years
so i hope that i'm a better leader and a
better basketball player in four years
than i am now yeah okay this is this is
a serious question but
at what age do you think people will
stop talking about how old you are
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't know because
i do
being a father and
being five years in the league now i
like
i might like carry myself as like an
older person
and then i'll be somewhere and i'm like
i'll say something like i was born in 98
and everybody at the table be like oh my
god oh yeah yeah you were born in 98
and i was like damn i am only 24. yeah
but i never feel like it like
being in my profession
i'm always around older people
deuces for now
i just feel so much older and it's like
i don't want to be i love being young
yeah
um
so i've probably got like
once i get the 26 i got a yeah they
stopped it he's only 19. yeah because i
was gonna say there's always he's only
19 and now everything is like you know
he's doing this and he's just 24 and
tell me if this makes sense but in some
ways
i wonder if you being so good
so early
like
hurt you because it like skewed the
expectations of you
like now what everybody wants from you
it's like well you have already had
these great years
and so now it's like every year is going
to have to be more but you've done the
great stuff
do you ever feel that i mean that's part
of it like
you know
i'm certain that some people probably
think i've been in the league longer
than i actually had right
um because you know had so much you know
early success
um
but
you know i wouldn't change it i would
rather it be how it is and
you know
just start winning i guess if if that
makes sense
um
but you know people's expectations just
continue to grow
the thing that does like bother me
sometimes is like
um i hear stuff like he's one of the
best young players in the league i was
like well
you don't have to put the young part
like no i'm one of the best players and
it's not like i'm
arrogant or anything it's like
you know age doesn't matter like we all
play on the same court in the same
league
you know you one of the best guys that
you're not so yeah i never really liked
that he's one of the best young players
yeah no i agree with that and on that on
this show we talk a lot about star and
superstar
are you a superstar right now
what is a superstar let's head out
that is that is why we talk about a lot
we go back and forth all the time how do
you define superstar because i feel like
i'm the poster child of like is he a
superstar yet yeah you are for one i
feel like it's like you and luca
for one
i feel like that debate has been going
on for like a year and a half two years
and it always
i was always curious because i was like
wait did i ever say like prematurely i
was a superstar and i wasn't yet or
did my mom tweet something or like why
was i the person of like is he a
superstar yet no or yes or
like why was i the person for that
debate
i i never wanted like what did i do yeah
like how did you end up being that guy
like cause that's the narrative around
like is he a superstar yeah well i think
it goes back to what i was saying about
you being so good so early and what you
were bringing to boston it was just easy
for everyone to put that conversation on
you because everything that we talk
about that debate
you almost embodied it
so what is it how do you because
everybody has a different definition of
what a superstar is for sure some people
say there's a list of six some people
have a list of 12 and
so what would how would you define what
a superstar is i think that there
aren't that many how many i'm kind of in
that
i would say
six what superstars i think there's a
lot of stars i have probably more
stringent like criteria of what i think
a superstar is because then you start so
you'll start naming them and then you
say well
is this player actually in the same
category as
a lebron or steph and so if you have
those two people is kind of what your
marker is
what other players are in that tier i
got you do you get what i'm saying i'm
almost afraid to ask you like is this
person a superstar
like i want to ask you like is because
you said there's only six i and my head
thing is six but i mean you that doesn't
matter to me you can ask is kyrie irving
a superstar
yes
kyrie is so okay
do you want me to say what i think about
you i agree okay
but then
is
damian lillard a superstar
i think that damien has all of the
superstar qualities
but it's hard to put him in it in this
moment because of
he just like needs a little more but
obviously like he has that in him he's a
little more i mean he's gotta win he's
gotta get there like that it to me
that's a that's some of it so you
think championships matter but it's not
even like for example i think that this
year
solidified you in that conversation i
don't think that in the beginning of the
season i would have said that about you
and i've been open about that i've
tweeted like he's on the way to being a
superstar like you're very clearly a
star but i think now you're like
you're able to say that because of what
you have proven there is something to
what you prove and it's also like
what does being a superstar mean if
there's 20 of them
there's more than six but how many would
you say there are
i don't know
4 12 14.
damian lillard is a superstar yeah i
mean and i get i'm not like saying
you're wrong in that i think that we
have like our different opinions i love
dame i think he's incredibly talented
but i also just think if we're coveting
what superstar is
at what point are you almost like
changing the meaning of so many people
can be one and maybe there are 15 14. i
just think that's it's a difference in
opinion there can be superstars and then
there are a few guys in the league right
now that are like all-time greats so yes
like there is a difference between
katy braun and dame
like
those are two of the greatest
and like top
10 12 players of all time
and while they might not be top 15
player of all time he it wasn't nba 75
so like
the sixes you might be referring to are
like probably like all time top 20
players mm-hmm but that's fair
but you are you a superstar
i guess like
the
words and the criteria that's the thing
the criteria is different for everyone i
absolutely agree with that and i don't
think it's like what one person says is
like
the bible
you know like i get why someone would
say
damn is like
that's a very valid argument dame is a
fantastic basketball player for sure you
know
for sure and it's it
like i value your opinion and there are
some people on tv that
they're i don't value their parents like
y'all know what you're talking about but
i don't know it's just like do i have
the respect of the people i play against
do they know like
you know
what i'm capable of and they got a game
plan a certain way like if i've earned
that respect of the guys that i got to
compete against night in the night out
and they know what i bring to the table
then
you know that's all that that's what
really matters because they really know
totally and again and i want your take
on this too
i have always said i think players
should be involved in the voting of all
things like i think that it's ridiculous
that when we're doing all this voting
players don't have a voice you really
should only care about like what the
players think of you they are the ones
that know you inside and out they're who
you go up against i know that you have
had
some words about how we can change this
uh voting process
please tell us um how you would like to
change it
um
i mean there's no a thousand percent
perfect way to change it but i do think
it's unfair to us and unfair to you guys
there's a lot of pressure
for you guys to have to
make a decision that could directly
impact somebody's
what they could like how much money they
can earn
um
you know so that's a lot to be asked of
you guys
um
you know and there's a lot of talk of
like should it be positions or should it
be the five best players because
embiid was
second in mvp voting but then made
second team all nba
agree that was yeah if you don't know
sports that just yeah that that doesn't
make sense
um
i'm on i'm with you it should be
positionless it's just like the top
player should be all nba because then
it's like if you're getting votes as
like a guard but you could also get
votes as a forward it's like
it gets difficult yeah so the year i did
make it when i you know missed out on
you know earning that
bonus uh
you know i had to kind of split my votes
up between some people thought i was a
guard some people thought i was a
forward and if it would have just been
like all forward
the point system i would have made it
and it's just like too tricky yeah
you know
maybe
and it's tough because
you know
i could say people in the front office
should be the ones that vote because
they you know
really watch every game but
you know they have their own agendas at
time and
i don't know um
you know i could talk on and on for days
about this but
um
you know there's just some things that
just don't sit right with me yeah no
unless i agree i have said on here
multiple times the the process should be
changed i would understand why a player
is frustrated with how it happens like
all of that makes total sense so i get
that um one more little bucket of
questions i want to ask you before we go
to fan questions in here and i'm out of
your hair um who interviewed you first
me or anthony novelli
the kid i went to yesterday i watched
the youtube video oh
he did because he did that was like
seventh grade okay i was like
what freshman year eighth grade freshman
yeah eighth grade freshman year when you
didn't decide to go to u of i
you have a wealth of great young videos
on youtube do you know how to tie a tie
uh
honestly no
and it's wild because i was in a
like a web design class and
like we had to make a youtube account
and post videos and
you know now that video has millions of
views so many views there's like six
million i just looked at it and i'm like
i never would have thought when i made
that how to tie video
um that they would have i mean but the
internet finds everything yeah a very uh
very young jason and speaking of young
jason's i know that you call deuce
you're minnie me a lot um he's so lively
has the best personality
when you see
what deuce has become
to the world
how does it make you feel are you a
little uncomfortable with how famous
deuce is now
yeah extremely uncomfortable
because
he didn't ask for that
and
you know i
asked for it by being who i am so it
comes with the job but
um
you know there's a lot of things that i
have to like think about and worry about
as he gets older and you know is going
to venture off into this world
um
that you know makes me a little
uneasy like the thought of him going to
school
of like
maybe i need to send like a security
guard to school um
to just make like you know maybe not be
in the classroom would be outside the
classroom
and
that's not normal
i keep saying it's not normal but it's
like things that
i have to really think about
um
because for one we live in a crazy
crazy world
and you know i always think about like
when i was growing up
you know my mom if i was especially when
i started driving like
she would ask me where am i going who's
going to be there send me the address
let me know and i was like mom like
relax i'm gonna be all right and she's
always telling me like you won't
understand until you have one of your
own
and
i feel that more than anything like
i am terrified for him to
go to school go on a field trip go on
the aau trip just like
the thought of not being able to be
there to protect them or like
whatever is a as a is a frightening
feeling so yeah i wish he could stay
this age forever but he is growing up
extremely fast um
and
he is a brand like yeah deuce is
extremely
well known and
with social media and everything i'm
trying to navigate
um
trying to navigate that the right way as
much as possible but i mean even saying
that being a like what percentage of
being a parent
is being scared
you know they say you can't live your
life in fear but it's like
there's a appropriate level of fear to
be like prepared
um
i don't know the percent but it's high
it's
high
yeah it is high he hasn't even went to
school yet uh
like you know i'm very laid back
but like when it comes to deuce
like uh like we went on
we took a couple visits to some like
preschools to talk and see the um the
schools and facilities and
you know in my mind it's preschool how
much can they learn
saying they're gonna take naps and play
and be with other kids yeah but
you know my mom and his mom asking all
the the
the right questions and things like that
and
the only question i ever have is like
not even question just like
you know if we decide to send him here
um i need to know that it's okay that
you know if i'm coming from practice or
we have a day off if i just want to come
up here and sit in the classroom and
watch him all day like that has to be
okay
um because
you know
i'm i'm very mild-mannered and laid back
but like
about him i will
like i know people say like they don't
play about their kids i don't play about
i don't play about my son so
try and figure it out
what do you want deuce to know about the
way you love him
what do i want him to know about the way
i love him the way i love him
um
you know when they say
you love someone like you know they be
like i killed somebody for you that's
how much i love you
when you like
would give your life for somebody
have you ever seen john q
like
i didn't understand that until i had a
child
and
like that was an extreme you know
dramatic movie but
yeah like push come to show if i got
something and i'm the only person that
can give it to him and that means giving
my life up like i wouldn't think twice
about it
so
i think people without kids don't
understand that that love because most
people without kids wouldn't give their
life up for somebody
but if it meant that he would be okay
and that he would
live his life uh i wouldn't i wouldn't
think twice about it so like
that's how much i love him yeah and i'm
sure even at a young age like he knows
and feels that
you know
we and you and i have had conversations
about about parents and the things that
you know can pass down to your children
and things like that
but when you think about yourself and
you think about deuce
what is a character trait of yours that
you're like
i want him to also be this what is
something about yourself
you do not want him to be like
i want him to be as confident as i am
and as i've always been
um
you know in any situation in any room
that he walks in
to
you know always walk in with your head
high and
you know
um
as yourself you know never
never change because of the company
you're around or the room that you're in
you know always be genuine and authentic
and you know people accept that
great if they don't then that's not the
room you should be in so
that's something i've i've always been
i've always been myself i've always been
confident regardless of
you know who i was with where i was at
and that's something that you know i
want to instill in him
something i
don't want
him to do that i did is
have a kid at 19
you know
get married first have a family
not that i regret it is the best thing
ever but
uh you know having a kid at 19 may not
be the most ideal thing
to do
yeah you know when i see like you induce
i really do think about how close you
and your mom are like that's your best
friend um
she is like i feel like you almost can't
explain you without explaining miss
brandy she's the best um what is your
first memory of your mom
my first memory yeah
um
that is a great question my first memory
um
ah
man
that's so me i don't know i used to i
slept in the bed with my mom until i was
like 13.
um
i was such a mama's boy like
anytime her friends would come over and
they would be playing spades at the
table
like i would
fall asleep on her lap because i like
had separation anxiety i i never wanted
to be away from my mom uh
so just you know everything like you we
used to watch love jones together when i
was a kid that was my favorite movie
um
and players club
you know i probably should have been
watching that at five but you know i was
well your mom has memory that she wants
to share with you
that i'm going to show you
you know i uh i was with jason at
katie's premiere and he says to me who's
my video going to be and i was like i
didn't have a video
but i said you know what there is nobody
he would want to hear from more than one
of his parents so
here is a
message from your mom
hey jay it's me
um when taylor gave me this assignment
the objective was to
share some story that you've never heard
or tell you something i've never told
you
to solicit in a some sort of organic
response and i have struggled because we
don't really keep secrets i know
everything we have such an open
relationship that um i couldn't think of
anything that i've
haven't shared with you before however
the one thing that came to my mind that
really resonated with me is if you
remember when you were a little boy
about six seven eight years old
and i used to be in the bathroom outside
your room and i would
come in your room with a brush or a
remote and stick it in your face while
you're in the middle of playing a game
or something and i would say ask you all
these impromptu questions and ask you
what are you going to say when they ask
you this and what are you going to say
when they ask you that
you will often be annoyed and you would
look at me and you would ask mom who's
going to ask me these questions and i
would say duh the reporters from like
espn and tnt and
you know you're going to be one of the
best players in the world
and you would laugh and
you would say then you would roll your
eyes again and you would say well you
have to feel that way you're my mom
well guess what
there's a lot of people feel that way
now turns out i was right
and
i know at that young age you didn't know
but again
it wasn't but maybe a year or two later
shortly thereafter in the fourth grade i
think that you even began to realize
like this is a realistic goal a
realistic dream and um ever since then i
have watched you
relentlessly
attack every goal every accomplishment
everything that you've ever wanted to do
i've watched you put in the work i've
watched you have the level of commitment
and discipline
and passion that is honestly unmatched
i've never seen anyone at that young of
an age
and um people are often in all of my
accomplishments being a single mom and
going to law school and all of that
but that's because they didn't get a
chance to watch you and i have been in
all of you since you were a little boy
and just the discipline the maturity the
level of commitment
the dedication the passion the work
ethic everything that you've put into
perfecting your craft and pursuing your
dreams has just been
amazing to watch
and
what's even more impressive is that it's
great of a basketball player you are and
by the way you are one of the best
players in the world
you're an even better dad like by a
landslide and so
i am just honored to be your mom i'm
grateful for the opportunity to get to
be on this journey with you
i am um just blessed to be able to watch
you
not only pursue your dreams but be
the very best dad
that deuce could ever ask for
and i just want you to always remember
how proud i am of you
that i'm your biggest fan and always
will be deuce may try to argue with that
with me but um he can be one b
um but i just want you to always
remember we always have your back we'll
always be in your corner
and i love you and i'm proud of you and
um
just to think this is everything that
you have accomplished thus far at 24 and
we're just getting started it's pretty
scary
so um we're just going to sit back and
continue to enjoy this journey with you
and i just have one last question
what's next superstar
all right to end you have to answer your
mom's question what's next what's next
superstar um
well i haven't won a championship yet
and i haven't been to mvp
so uh
that's what's next that's next on the
list um
[Music]
yeah that was cool yeah
that was cool i i loved that video and
again i just think that you all's
relationship is so special and
everything she's saying about you as a
dad is is so true so thank you for doing
this and above all else i have i've
known you very long time i'm very proud
of you i'm happy for you i'm thankful
for your friendship i'm thankful that
you gave us this time here and
onward
always more thank you of course
appreciate it thank you
[Music]
you